- I described the event,
and I, the simple inquiry was,
by chance are there any
photographs from that parade?
I got a call, we have two photographs.
Wonderful.
And frankly, I would
have been perfectly happy
with either of those photographs.
The doggedness of the archive's people,
the behavior that I am so appreciative of,
is that with no additional
prodding from me,
continued the search.
In the very last contact sheet,
in the very last row
in that contact sheet,
caused me to look in astonishment.
And to realize that there
were two photographs.
One of Robert, reaching for my hand.
And the real treasure, a
photograph of him shaking my hand.
- But, and I was kind of hoping that maybe
you would find yourself, but honestly,
I mean how often does that really happen?
A random encounter like the
one that Mr. MacDonald had
with Robert Kennedy, in the
middle of a parade in Boston,
there's very little likelihood
that we would find something like that.
When you're working with the public,
and you're helping them
with their requests,
especially their personal requests,
the ones that they remember personally,
or their family member was involved,
or they have a really close
connection with whatever
they were asking for,
that is the best feeling.
- The photographer clicking
in that nano second,
is truly a one in a million possibility.
It's 50 years later.
I ended up getting the photograph
that I didn't even know existed.